Speaker 1: Today, I'm going to be speaking
with Greg Barich, who's the author of Criminology
on Trump and also emeritus professor of criminology
and criminal justice at Eastern Michigan University.
It's really great having you on.
I appreciate your time today.
Speaker 4: Thank you.
Speaker 1: So in the book, you really do an
analysis of Trump and the Trump family and
the presidency and the business enterprise.
Trump a through through sort of a criminology
lens, the idea of Trump operating as a sort
of pseudo mob boss, in a sense.
Can you first lay out the kind of general
approach and perspective that you used here
and what and why you did it in this way?
Speaker 4: Okay.
Well, I'm a criminologist and I study crime
and I study the administration of justice.
And I do so in a very broad based manner in
the sense that I examine all laws, whether
they be civil or criminal.
Constitutional.
International.
So he was a perfect subject, a perfect object.
And what what I think makes my analysis unique
or different from literally the thousands
of other books on Trump is that it is really
the first and only criminal biography of Donald
Trump, and it tries to give the 45th president
his rightful place in the history of U.S.
crime.
What it attempts to explain systemically or
systematically throughout his entire life
is his uncanny ability to get over it.
Regardless of whether we're talking business
economics, whether we're talking politics,
whether we're talking interpersonal relationships.
He has the ability to harm and abuse and to
always escape the consequences or almost always
escape at least criminally.
He's fully escaped civilly.
He's been held accountable more than once.
Speaker 1: So let's let's talk about a few
examples.
Before he was president, Trump would notoriously
sue lots of people, and the outcomes of those
lawsuits varied pretty dramatically.
And in some cases, it seemed as though the
lawsuit may have been a tool to maybe cover
up his own preexisting wrongdoing.
Can you talk a little bit about the use of
lawsuits?
Speaker 4: Right.
Well, as many of your readers may know or
many of your listeners may know, Trump's mentor
and surrogate father was.
Oh, yes.
How am I having a blank here all time?
The McCarthy hearings prosecutor.
Och.
Speaker 1: Whose name I also don't remember.
Speaker 4: Right.
How is this crazy?
You know, where's my Roy Cohn?
Speaker 1: Ro Marcus.
Roy Marcus Cohn.
Yeah.
Speaker 4: Right.
Right.
Okay.
So so Cohn is his his first mentor and surrogate
father and really teaches him the art of weaponizing
the law and the two of them over a case involving
housing discrimination in projects owned by
his father throughout New York.
Donald retained Cohn to represent them, and
this is where it all began.
For Donald to use the law against the law
and to always countersue, to never acknowledge
defeat.
So that's where it first began.
And whether he wins or loses the case, it
almost, almost is immaterial to Donald, because
at the end of the day, he will always claim
victory that that he won just as he won the
election.
He knows he didn't win the election.
He knows he didn't win the cases that he claims
to.
But that's his narrative.
Speaker 1: Can you talk about other sometimes
the term is used that he had a way to skirt
the law in his business career, which is skirting
the law different than breaking the law.
Speaker 4: I you know, I can't tell you, you
know, that there's any legal meaning to the
notion of skirting the law.
Right.
Evading the law.
It's like not getting caught.
It's not really not breaking the law.
He he's he's, you know, engaged in lawlessness
pretty much day in and day out through various
types of business arrangements that he is
he he's put put together.
Speaker 1: What are some examples of that?
Speaker 4: Well, the best example is the way
in which beginning with Fred Senior Donald's
Donald's father, that he began to transfer
his enormous wealth.
To his children, some of which you could legitimately
pass on and some of which he created shell
companies that were companies in name only.
He created the arrangements where Donald and
his siblings became owners of certain companies
within the Trump organization, and so he was
billing them for work that he wasn't doing
that.
That's an example Donald has continued with
with that into with at least three of his
children that were aware of Eric and JR and
Ivanka.
Speaker 1: When we think about the Trump presidency.
He's really gotten away with the most kind
of basic pedestrian, just kind of shrugging
off the things that are thrown at him.
I mean, he recently had four cell phones subpoenaed
and he wrote, I lost the phones.
I don't know where the phones are now, but
what's going to come of that?
We don't know.
Probably, probably nothing.
Endless requests for documents that seem to
be legitimate requests, subpoenas, etc..
Now, here, it's executive privilege and there
is a political witch hunt and it seems as
though he just gets away with it.
Is that, in fact the way that it has gone
criminally?
Speaker 4: That is in fact, the way it has
gone.
I mean, he's yet to be prosecuted for a single
criminal offense.
Yes.
In his life.
So it's certainly got him that way there in
terms of his civil litigation.
He has an impressive record.
Maybe he's lost 4050 cases, one 300.
The rest had been drawers.
Hmm.
Speaker 1: And when you say a draw, is that
good for Trump or good for someone else?
Speaker 4: It's usually good for Trump.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 4: Because, you know, Trump has an
interesting habit when he wins a case, you
and I, the taxpayers, pay his attorneys.
And when he loses a case, he stiffs his attorneys.
Speaker 1: Right.
Right.
When it comes to the current investigations,
you know, I have people in my audience who
are convinced I mean, convinced that at some
point Trump's going to face criminal prosecution.
I just don't think so.
And when we go through what's being looked
at right now, there's the January 6th committee
who could make referrals depending on what
they find to the justice system, they could,
although it's not their main charge as as
described.
There's the New York investigation where we
actually saw some investigators resign because
they got the impression that there's not really
any interest in actually prosecuting Donald
Trump.
You've got the Georgia investigation for possible
election fraud.
I mean, is there any shot, any of this stuff
goes anywhere?
Speaker 4: Yeah, there's always there's always
a shot that goes somewhere.
I think that what people want to know is whether
Attorney General Merrick Garland, whether
or not he's going to come come forward.
And, you know, people have been very wishy
washy and, you know, wanting this to have
occurred already.
What I think is significant, a couple of things
I think are significant as to why I think
he ultimately will, oh, prosecute.
I mean, I've been very you know, you know,
I've been mixed as to whether he will or he
won't in part.
One sign was Eric.
Former Attorney General Eric Holder.
HOLDER thank you.
Eric Holder, who is an institutionalist who,
for example, didn't prosecute the 10,000 security
fraudsters on Wall Street, gave them all a
pass.
He thought that in all likelihood, because
presidents in the past had been given passes
by the next attorney general, that this would
be the same situation with with Trump.
He's come around and thinks differently now
that we understand that this was involving
a significant number of elected and appointed
officials and how big the conspiracy was.
He now thinks that, you know, there should
be a prosecution.
His change in position is significant.
But I think last but not least, because of
the historical situation that we find ourselves
in, in terms of autocrats and Democrats and
struggles with Ukraine and Russia and elsewhere,
that.
It becomes rather embarrassing and it becomes
a slap in the face of so-called American democracy
when we prove that somebody and somebodies
who have power are above the law.
It's not a very good marketing tool for the
United States.
And I think that political pressure, because
it's on the world stage, is also adding substance
to the fact that I think Garland is going
to.
Speaker 1: Go after him.
How long could it take?
Speaker 4: Before he prosecutes.
Yeah.
In my mind.
It could.
It could go as long as before the primary
of 2024.
Okay.
I mean, the problem is, if they go after him
and if he can keep the delays from the actual
trial occurring before the primary begins,
then he'll be able to probably sidestep whether
he wins or loses 2024, because I'm convinced
that whether he loses or not, they will the
Republicans and company will actually steal
the election.
So therefore, he can keep the attorney general
and the Justice Department away from him to
2029.
Speaker 1: Which so I don't want to go I don't
want to miss something you just said.
That's a big deal.
You believe that in 24, the sort of trial
run that was 2020, some of those different
ideas that were floated for how to take an
election, they didn't win.
You think they might successfully use those
tools in 24?
Speaker 4: I think they're well on their way.
They have control of 26 out of the 50 state
legislative bodies who could and are, in fact,
preparing themselves to overturn the election.
Speaker 1: Wow.
Okay.
Let's come back to that.
The many armchair mental health professionals
during the Trump era would maybe not diagnose
but suggest that Donald Trump could be narcissistic,
that he might be delusional, that he's self-deluded,
that he's mentally ill in different ways,
that he lies uncontrollably, pathological
lies, etc..
One of the things that you write, if I understand
it correctly, is that while all of those things
may be true, you don't believe that any of
it is the sort of explanation or ultimate
cause of the criminality and the lying and
the deception that in that sense, he knows
what he's doing.
Am I accurately summarizing your position?
Speaker 4: You are spot on.
That's exactly what we're arguing.
He is a rational player.
He may be, you know, suffering from a variety
of mental illnesses.
But when it comes to his day to day affairs,
he is a rational player.
He clearly knows that he did not win the election.
He is not self deluded for a moment.
He's a con, a performance artist, and he's
just doing the script.
Speaker 1: So how do you know that?
And I guess with the election thing as an
example, I've gone back and forth over time.
Does Trump think he won the election or does
he know that it's that he didn't really win?
And I was kind of on the side of, he's lying.
It's a con.
But more recently, we've had reports from
behind the scenes that he was privately talking
to people and saying that he won, which doesn't
sound like something he would do if he knew
he didn't really win.
Speaker 4: It depends on who he's privately
talking to.
Okay.
He wouldn't say that to Jared.
He wouldn't say it to Monica, but he would
say it to the people who have all been subpoenaed
for.
Speaker 1: Like Mark Meadows, for example.
He would keep up the lie with Mark Meadows.
Speaker 4: He would keep off the lie with
those people.
I mean, Jared knows better.
You know, he he knows that, you know, it wasn't
stolen, just like Bannon knows it wasn't stolen.
Speaker 1: So then you're so.
So your assertion is when it comes to the
audience that needs to hear the lies, Trump
knows he's not telling the truth.
Speaker 4: Oh, absolutely.
Absolutely.
That's why he's such a great performer.
Mm hmm.
Speaker 1: When it comes to zooming out a
little bit now.
Sure.
One of the conversations that took place a
bunch of times while Trump was president was,
are our checks and balances sort of like robust
enough?
And one of the kind of answers that was zeroed
in on was, generally speaking, they are.
But the founding fathers never imagined someone
like Trump would be elected.
And that's why there aren't more checks and
balances that would have prevented some of
the things that Donald Trump did.
What what's your sense of that?
Did the checks and balances fail?
Speaker 4: I'm not sure the checks and balances
were where were tested until now.
Right.
You know, so, so.
And they clearly it remains to be seen whether
or not they work or they don't work.
From my perspective, with respect to the popular
story or explanation that the founding fathers
never thought that an oligarch or that some,
you know, very wealthy person could be doing
similar things to Donald.
And they knew about kings.
And I mean, they knew about the danger of
of of the parties reverting, you know, they
didn't care for parties, but yeah, so I don't
buy that.
But, you know, I, I'm not that much of an
expert to know they're fair.
Speaker 1: The book is Criminology on Trump.
We've been speaking with the book's author,
Greg Baric, who's also emeritus professor
of criminology and criminal justice at Eastern
Michigan University.
So appreciate your time today.
Thank you so much.
Speaker 4: Thank you, David.